d'interviews bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
en cette fin d'année vous avez parcouru
le monde vous allez sur le terrain ou
devant des gens qui vivent les plus
grandes misères du monde si je vous
demandais quelques mots pour décrire
votre année 2010 8 et surtout l'année de
ces gens là devraient quelques mots donc
je pense c'est une année qui était qui
était difficile ce serait un euphémisme
s'est indigné aussi que je crois que il
ya des moments qui doivent être mis sous
sous le spotlight et c'est le fait que
c'est l'année où on a criminalisé
beaucoup le migrant et selanne est aussi
con à criminaliser les gens qui ont
apporté des secours aux migrants et je
pense que c'est important d'être dit
haut et fort parce que c'est vraiment je
vous dirais un début de dérapage sur nos
ce que j'appelle nos engagements
collectifs qu'on a faits au xxème siècle
à travers la déclaration des droits de
l'homme à travers la convention des
réfugiés en 1951 alors évidemment il ya
deux interfaces ici à la fois ceux qui
veulent faire reconnaître leur droit
d'asile pour ceux qui veulent venir au
secours de ces gens là la plus récente
images qu'on a c'est cette petite fille
de 7 ans qui ont suivi la caravane avec
un parrain et qui meurt après être entré
sur le territoire américain
de toute façon léman détention c'est par
les parents les enfants dans ce cas s'il
a peu de cinéma est là qu est ce que ça
vous inspire cette demande mais c'est
une histoire qui est atroce et qui est
scandaleuse
c'est quand même assez incroyable qu'au
xxième siècle aujourd'hui des gens qui
fuient la violence pour un futur arrive
à mourir à part sans une frontière et je
dis ça parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
disent oui mais ses parents le devrait
savoir qu'on a on n'amène pas des
enfants avec eux moi j'ai toujours vous
savez la motivation d'un parent pour
offrir un futur à ses enfants est
imbattable
hergé mais de mur assez haut pour les
empêcher de venir heureux jamais des
politiques restrictives dissuasive
suffisamment reste régnante pour
empêcher les gens quand on veut un futur
pour ses enfants
on est prêt à tout voir a payé de sa vie
c'est ce qui arrive donc en amérique
centrale avec ce flux migratoire vous
êtes allés sur le terrain vous l'avez
constaté ce désespoir la ce besoin de
fuir la violence
oui donc je vais je faire une visite
régionale
je suis allé au el salvador honduras
guatemala et le mexique
et l'histoire est toujours la même c'est
cette histoire-là de gens qui sont
obligés de fuir pour leur sécurité
on a fait même des entretiens plus de 70
% ont des histoires de violence ils ont
perdu soit quelqu'un de leur famille ou
soient eux mêmes ils ont été mis
sous sous menace et c'est normal qu'à un
moment donné on dit ça suffit
pourquoi pas ce que je dis toujours il
convient de parents qui voudraient
partir le matin se pose la question
toute la journée pendant qu'ils son
travail s'ils vont retrouver leurs
enfants le soir à la maison parce que
peut-être il va avoir été enlevée c'est
normal qu'un moment de non dit ça suffit
mais ce qui est aujourd'hui le plus
grand drame de ça c'est qu'une fois
qu'on quitte on peut plus revenir
et ce qui se passe et qu'on rentre dans
un espèce de cycle de parcours
migratoire que j'appelle en cercle donc
est une boucle
parce que on se fait renvoyer des états
unis au point départ et quand qu'on
revienne à sa communauté
on c'est un geste de trahison quand on
est parti on est obligé de reprendre la
route et en prenant la route c'est
toujours la même chose on extorqués on
aimait manipuler on est violé un point
tel que les femmes avant de prendre la
route de la migration demande de la
contraception parce qu'ils savent que ça
va être un mondial et oui le savent
ouais et l'autre interface et lorsqu on
criminalise ceux qui viennent en aide et
vendre à l'esprit de votre bateau
aquarius dont avaient dû cesser les
activités parce que justement on vous
traite comme si c'étaient des criminels
oui donc et puis dix jours on a dû
arrêter nos activités avec le bateau
aquarius qu on opérait avec sos
méditerranée c'est un bateau qui avait
sauvé plusieurs dizaines milliers de
personnes là dans la mer méditerranée
cette année et on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya très peu de bateaux qui peuvent peut
faire des secours en mer
la raison étant que quand ils ont des
migrants à leur bord et ne sont pas
capables de l'aider embarqué dans un
pardessus sécuritaire et du coup ils ne
veulent pas prendre des gens repêcher
des gens donc ne pas payer accueillant
pour ce bateau leurs noms aient cessées
l'italie c'est fini y'a pas moyen d en
juin l'année dernière je crois que la
terre entière avait su on avait plus de
600 personnes dans notre bateau et
pendant plus de dix jours
on à naviguer de port en port dans les
eaux internationales pour trouver un
port d'accueil et donc c'est c'était
extrêmement je dire pour pour les gens
sur le bateau qui venait d'être sauvée
il était dans un an dans un désarroi
total
et en plus juste la gestion de taux pour
nous et éthéré parce qu'on on est on
n'est pas aménagé pour avoir 600
personnes pour une durée une telle durée
les manquer de vivies manqué de soins il
manquait de personnel et vos
travailleurs sont qu'à risque également
d'être arrêté détenu même et donc tout
récemment nous on fait face aujourd'hui
à des as des as délégation de mauvais
de mauvaise gestion des déchets et donc
on est on est d'aider des codes légales
contre nous et c'est aujourd'hui c'est
ça c'est que on criminalise les gens qui
apportent des secours c'est une façon de
dissuader les gens de d'apporter un
geste de solidarité envers des gens qui
sont dans le besoin
est ce la même chose pour le citoyen
français qui accueille un migrant qui a
traversé la frontière ont le vue est ce
la même chose aussi avec un médecin sans
frontières personne n'était pas renié et
moi j'ai toujours mais quand même au
21ème siècle pour se poser des questions
sur nous même en sachant qu' on est ce
qu'on est ok avec le fait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est illégal de sauver des vies dans la
mer méditerranée
c'est incroyable et donc d vous avez
sauvé grâce à ce bateau là trente mille
personnes ces dernières années où je
cette année ça cette année c'était 30
minutes au total depuis 2015 c'était
80000 personnes 80000 personnes plus de
bateaux plus de sauvetage des milliers
de morts oui on poursuit le bilan de
2018 avec la présidente de médecins sans
frontières docteur johan guillou pour
qui très certainement la crise des
migrants et la crise humanitaire de 2018
mais peut-être aussi dans ce début de
21e siècle on est quand même en 2019
bientôt des sources d'espoir quelque
part vous étiez très préoccupé par la
situation au myanmar vous étiez très
préoccupé par la situation au yémen et
des pourparlers de paix sans paraître
d'abord du yémen est ce qu'il ya de
l'espoir quelque part pour le yémen je
crois qu'on peut se permettre d'avoir je
pourrais dire
oui un peu d'espoir car en théorie la
trêve va commencer demain soir à 21h
c'est sûr que au travers de week end ça
n'a pas changé nous mais ça sent
français reçoit nos endroits les plus
déployées on travaille dans douze
hôpitaux 12 gouvernants on est un acteur
qui depuis le début du conflit on a
quand même soigné plus de 90 mille
blessés de guerre et de trauma donc
c'est un de nos endroits les plus actifs
en conflit aujourd'hui le yémen donc on
est inquiet mais
on a un petit peu d'espoir parce que
c'est pas la première fois qu'on nous
promet une trêve
donc on attend avec beaucoup je voudrais
dire d'anxiété mais en même temps aussi
d'espoir on est avec l'ailier minutes
puis on espère que ça va que ça va se
tasser un peu parce que une c'est cette
guerre là qui était une guerre
d'attrition c'est une guerre on sait que
plus de 90% des biens sont importés
aujourd'hui mais les mamans peuvent pas
se déplacer parce que pas assez
d'essence pour aller accoucher dans des
hôpitaux
on sait aussi que c'était une guerre qui
était elle pas épargner les civils
beaucoup et notamment quelques-uns de
nos hôpitaux ont été bombardés mais
aussi des écoles des marchés des
mariages des autobus on se rappelle très
bien d'enfants donc c'était une guerre
qui était qui était atroce et une guerre
contre les civils
donc savoir que peut-être demain 21h des
choses vont changer on attend comme vous
un apaisement possible un appel d'un
possible
on pourrait être plus sage de ce côté là
de côté des intérêts politiques et on a
vu les enfants mourir
cette famine aussi artificielle dans ce
sens qu'elle est créé par les effets
politiques de cette guerre-là tout à
fait donc le fait qu'on ne permet pas
l'entrée de biens dans le pays
donc du coup oui ça se traduit par par
des antilles ont failli on voulait autre
source d'espoir pour vous êtes très
engagé au congo phase aller bola qui a
fait en demandant le passé est là aussi
pour vous il ya de l'espoir il ya de
l'espoir parce que je me rappelle d'être
venu ici
vous parlez mon désespoir en 2014 et en
2015 et que même si la vie
apporte souvent des solutions est
parfaite aujourd'hui au nord kivu
c'est la deuxième épidémie en 2018
ceci a commencé le 1er août on parle de
plus de 500 personnes qui ont été
infectées mais je vous dirais la chose
qui est différente quand on se rappelle
de 2014 où on n'avait pas d'accès où on
n'avait pas de solution thérapeutique
non nos taxes ni près de 50000 personnes
et on a commencé les essais cliniques
avec quatre solutions thérapeutiques
depuis quelques jours donc c'est quand
même quelque chose qui on doit ce quand
même ce ce sont les joueurs un peu parce
que de partir de rien arriver à ça en
quelques années c'est pas rien c'est
beaucoup de combat pour vous à la fois
sur le terrain avec des équipes
extrêmement courageuse puis sur la scène
internationale de trouver des appuis du
soutien des délits pour vous permettre
de mener à terme vos missions pour moi
mais c'est surtout je pense pour nos
travailleurs sur la ligne de front où
sur la ligne de front des crises ou des
conflits qui je vous dirai pour moi je
rentrais de l'amérique centrale mais je
suis elle aussi en rdc cet été j'irai
que nos équipes sont sur demeure une
source d'inspiration non quarante cinq
mille travailleurs dans 71 pays
oui pour vous entendu l'ancien qui est
du coeur aussi pour l'héroïne gars c'est
à lomé allemand cette année donc
l'héroïne gars on se fait demeure
toujours au coeur de nos préoccupations
on sait que des discussions pour voir en
vo tour nous on plaide pour un retour
volontaire et on sait que depuis le
début de l'année il ya eu encore
quatorze mille personnes qui ont quitté
le miam art donc ça veut dire que si les
gens continuent de quitter le pays c'est
les chaussons ne sont pas revenus à la
normale et en terminant il faut
absolument parler de ce pacte de
migration qui pourrait être donc adopté
cyril contraignant mccoist pour vous ça
peut être une évolution intéressante
pour le sort de l'humanité mais je crois
que
la semaine dernière 164 pays ont adopté
le pack de migration et pour nous autres
codes à travers la lentille humanitaire
qu'est ce qui est important c'est le
fait qu'on disait que un migrant
aujourd'hui ne perd pas ses droits en
traversant les frontières
donc il doit être traité avec humanité
et avec dignité et donc ça c'est
important
l'autre chose aussi on le migrant n'est
pas un criminel et les gens qui aident
les migrants ne sont pas des criminels
et pour nous c'était essentiel de
remettre ça clairement dans les textes
en même temps quand on regarde ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis à la volonté de
rendre illégaux tous ces migrants leur
volant nier le droit d'asile
est ce que vous croyez que au delà du
texte pourrait être avalisé la au delà
du texte sur le terrain vous avez
l'espoir que les choses changent vous
pourrez promettre en méditerranée un
bateau demain matin ou l'été prochain
pour essayer d'arriver dans un port
européen
est ce que est ce qu'il reste des
obstacles importants
il reste des obstacles mais je pense que
c'est important aujourd'hui de mettre je
voudrais dire le
le spotlight sur les 164 pays qui ont
dit oui
et au lieu de mettre le spotlight sur
les quelques uns qui ont dit non parce
que c'est en fait en créant ce que
j'appelle un moment de bascule qui va
faire que ça va être tellement honteux
de ne pas accueillir un migrant paix de
nuit point de vue donner une façon
légale et sécuritaire de migrer parce
que il faut accepter aujourd'hui c'est
un phénomène qui arrive et que en
empêchant tout le monde est perdant
les pays sont perdants les migrants sont
perdants et donc si on veut avoir plutôt
une solution gagnante
il faut avoir des départs cours qui sont
sécurisées qui sont humanisé et qui
permette aux gens le choix de continuer
parce que ça n'arrêtera pas s'arrêtera
pas parce que je dis toujours la même
chose c'est que les motifs pour que les
gens viennent sont les mêmes
nous on est toujours aussi riche peu eux
sont toujours aussi pauvres et dans dans
la misère habilité et dans la violence
voilée dans ce pacte c'est la volonté
d'aller régler des problèmes
un portable dans ces pays là aussi il
est important de stabiliser ces pays là
on peut pas faire semblant qu'il n'y a
pas de raison pourquoi ils fuient leur
pays
qu'est ce qu'on vous souhaite pour 2019
à médecins sans frontières
qu'est ce qu'on ne souhaite mais moi je
crois que c'est important de s'assurer
que dans un moment d'incertitude où on
est toujours dans
dans l'espèce de d'atmosphère pop up de
populisme
il est important de dire que on a des
certaines valeurs et que on humanité
partagée puis l'humanité partager ses
c'est le fait qu'on ne criminalise pas
les gens qui cherchent un futur pour
humains gladiator jouera livre vous
souhaitez de réaliser vos rêves avant la
fin de votre mandat c'est lui en juin
prochain et que la mission de médecins
sans frontières soient toujours aussi
reconnue et que vous ayez le soutien les
fonds pour continuer cette mission leur
travail merci beaucoup
moi qui vous remercie